how much money should you ask for
i got a question from one of my youtube
viewers love you guys big key jones
uh you can hear my voice i am drinking
some tea i'm feeling really sick today
so big key jones wrote in on one of my
videos talking about how to get
companies to sponsor your events and he
said that was some great advice man
thanks
how much should you ask for should you
ask for it as a monthly or
one lump sum explain what is the kind of
partnership so here's the thing okay
when you are first starting to work with
a new client
a new sponsor a new relationship there's
always a lot of risk
right you don't know them more
importantly they don't know you and
they're afraid that it's not going to
work out right if you if you put on an
event you're asking for a sponsor
and it doesn't work out they don't want
to be left holding the bag saying hey
you know i invested this money it didn't
work out for me
what i try to encourage entrepreneurs to
do is reduce the risk as much as
possible
and what i mean by that is find a low
risk super
easy way for people to start to work
with you i
you know hopefully you're here in a
business mr bicky jones
that is not just a short-term thing
right you want to be around for a long
time and for that to happen
you have to build long-term
relationships with your clients you want
them to know you like you trust you
and have them think big key jones
delivers
that's what you need them thinking all
the time and so start off with something
small start off with something really
small something for them to say you say
yes to
easily something that's really low risk
for them get in there
over deliver like crazy give them crazy
amount of value understand what it is
they're really looking for
and then deliver that to them and then
the next time you have something coming
up
it's easy to go and ask for more and
more and more and more
one of the stories i like to tell is uh
i was doing a blog post
for a corporate client big telco
and they asked me to write uh 350 words
and they're gonna give me 500 bucks and
i get the link to my website
that's a pretty good deal i get 500
bucks i get linked to from a big website
i get to write about entrepreneurship
and they were hiring 10 people to do
this thing 10 different people
and here's the thing that happened so i
didn't just write 350 words
i wrote a thousand words or 1500 words i
added a video
i promoted my newsletter i tweeted about
it i got results on that post
and at the end of the day they compared
my post versus
all the other nine people that they
hired and mine was above and beyond the
best result that any of them
had ever gotten by a huge factor it
wasn't even close
like more than all of them combined and
so when it came down to
wanting to continue the relationship who
are they going to go with they're going
to go with me right because it gave them
such huge value
and i still increased my prices i went
from 500 to 1500 to 2500
and and that's you know gone up because
i give them great value and now i'm
signing year-long deals with companies
because they know what i can deliver and
so you have to start that relationship
if you go off
and you start saying i need a year-long
commitment it's going to cost you a
hundred thousand dollars
they're probably gonna say no right like
you gotta give them a low-risk way
to start the work with you get them
saying yes they don't have as many
layers to go through they don't have any
budgets to figure out because it's a
small amount and then show them
crazy amount of value and they want to
keep working with you and they'll come
back and say how can we do
more work with you we've got to figure
that out that's what you want them
saying
believe those are watching the video
thumbs up below
leave a question leave a comment wish me
to feel better
in the section below and uh you can
click on my face to subscribe to the
channel
thank you so much and i'll see you soon
you